all right i thought about it and did my
research before i decided to do this
video this afternoon as you guys know
january 11th today yes the iphone 4 was
announced on the verizon wireless 3g
network so here it goes here's my top
reasons not to buy the verizon iphone 4
right now
[Music]
so be sure to give this video a thumbs
up and share it with your friends to get
the word out it's more of a psa than a
review video that i usually do now don't
get me wrong before i start this i'm not
some sort of fanboy or i'm not trying to
bash apple in any way i'm just telling
you guys as an educated consumer and as
you are
that you might want to hold out until a
couple of months before you go for the
verizon iphone the new verizon iphone
does not have lte it's a 3g only phone
now you can view a couple of speed tests
that have been put up online with the
att version versus the verizon version
there is a small speed difference
verizon 3g is a little bit faster in
some areas but you got to keep in mind
this isn't much of an upgrade and this
probably isn't worth spending your att
contract ending money your termination
fee is going to be huge also something
you might need to note is that although
there are the the hotspot feature just
came out so there's the verizon hotspot
feature where you can have up to five
devices tethered there's no data and
calls at the same time on verizon which
i've been used to since i use wi-fi a
lot but that means if you're tethering a
couple devices and you get a call in
answering the call will end internet for
all those devices and last but not least
you guys know that the iphone 5 is most
likely going to be coming out this year
if not in a couple of months in june or
july this could leave a lot of you guys
buying the iphone 4 now and pre-ordering
it february march april may very very
disappointed when the iphone 5 comes out
likely on verizon 4g lte that will solve
all these features and really have the
real blunt of the force on the verizon
wireless network so verizon's uh
acquiring the iphone is really good at
competition for google and android and
it'll make it better for the consumer
overall having a lot more competition
but i still think you guys should wait
and your att network will probably see a
lot better performance increase when all
of them leave to the verizon network you
guys are the educated consumer you know
what's going down in june and july when
the iphone 5 is released so i advise you
to just wait until then and we'll see
what happens so this just been a quick
video from mkbhd please like this video
and spread the word hopefully people
don't overreact about the verizon iphone
coming out today until the next video
mkbhd signing out peace